- We're gonna get to that,
but first Dolly Parton.
So, I love her.
- Yeah.
- And I know you do too.
- Yes!
So what is the connection
with Dolly and your son?
- Okay, so I did this,
there was like a anthology series
- Yes, I know.
- called Heartstrings.
And I did one of the episodes and for
like the premiere of it Dolly
flew like all the casting crew
out to Dollywood and, you
know, she's so generous
and she's so just salt
of the earth, right?
So she would go around
to every single person
and she would talk to them
and just really look at
them right in the eye.
I took my mom and my son.
She sees my son and she
kind of does a double-take
and she's like, "Oh."
And she kind of caresses
his cheek and she's like,
"You have a face for the movies."
And so after that point
Wolf, my son, goes around
telling everybody that Dolly
Parton is his godmother.
(Kelly laughs)
I mean, apparently that's all it takes?
- I love the connection.
- Yeah, so it's like
- Point A to B.
- Exactly.
- She said I had a face for
the movies, she's my godmother.
- Also, by the way,
he knows that he wants Dolly
Parton to be his godmother.
- Don't we all?
- Who wouldn't?
- Of course!